[Musique]
24 août c'est une journée très
importante pour les ukrainiens
partout dans le monde parce que c'est la
journée de la
réactivation de l'indépendance de
l'ukraine c'est vrai que l'ukraine était
unie indépendante 1911 temps avec tous
ces difficultés historiques qu'on
connaît et pendant 70 ans elle était on
va dire occupée par les soviétiques et
le 24 août 1991 et les proclamer son
indépendance
[Musique]
la guerre continue les combats
continuent les militaires ukrainien ils
sont en train de combattre pour la
liberté et l'indépendance de l'ukraine
et cette année il ya beaucoup de
manifestations qui ont été organisées
par les ukrainiens en france et partout
dans le monde en ce qui concerne la
région parisienne donc il y à des
offices religieux qui sera célébré à la
cathédrale st volodymyr boulevard saint
germain à 17 heures à 18 heures nous
allons rencontrer place breteuil paris
6ème pour la marche solidaire avec
l'ukraine et pour aller jusqu'au champ
de mars au à 19 heures il y aura le
concert
yvan heures on va finir la soirée par un
pique nique
[Musique]
nous avons des réfugiés ukrainiens qui
sont hébergés en montigny le bretonneux
et ils vont participer au concert sur le
champ de mars demain à 19 heures
[Musique]